[Applaudissements]
valérie bénaïm qui a souvent un mii des
vestes à des jeunes hommes admis des
balades alors je vous dire vous avez
tous revoir cette scène tous ceux qui
ont déjà ramené une meuf
je vais ramener benhaim chez elle et je
vais tenter un truc alors attention tu
es très mal la bagnole attend ce nom
mais là on est en bas de chez toi donc
la gare d'olten multaq
je viens de te ramener ses frères avec
la musique de ghost voilà plus mettables
tu peux faire bon ben je suis très
content d'avoir vu ce soir c'était sympa
on me salue parce que je suis un petit
peu près c'est symbolique de un écho
très bon bah non attends métaireau
lourdes être été trop loin alors et
gérald jean louis pezant attend les
filles et ben oui mais oui elle salue le
qui dérape quoi
votre relationnel affligeant ce toit
c'est par une balade avec jean meyer va
le prendre à gauche qui va lui
alors là l'avez vous dire avait tout à
pas notre scénario donc là je le ramène
en voiture paraît qu'il a fait d'illégal
mais vous rêvez vous parce que oui qu'il
avait là déjà donc je leur amène coûteux
ça m'arrange pas du tout et pourtant
j'aurais posé leurs débuts naïma le
hasard fait autrement
bon bah ça lui est bourré de bodegas de
la voiture
[Applaudissements]
mais bon on est sillage havre est allé
bhatia justement hier qu'il y avait un
match de foot sur tf1